until you get to the very advanced level
pretty much all chess games are won or
lost based on either giving away pieces
simply putting them on squares they can
be captured to get better at that it's
the main way you do it is just learn how
to pay attention when you're playing
it's actually much harder than it sounds
for anyone but making sure you don't put
a piece on a square where it can be
captured or allow something very simple
now the next step to that is tactics now
probably most of you know some basic
tactics can anyone like name some basic
types of tactics yes forks that's
obviously what I have here anything else
yeah pin yep yeah double check can be a
tactic you what I want to start with
doing was basically cover all the
different basic types of tactics and
then work our way and then do a few
problems where you have to actually find
how to get them so first I want to cover
Queen Fork so you think you see it raise
your hand yeah
orange striped shirt very good so it's a
fork because you're attacking the king
and you're attacking the rook now this
is a very important thing to remember
what do you guys think of this Queen
Fork
not so good because your opponent could
take you so one of the things that
people one of the common mistakes that
people make is that they always they see
a fork in the leg ooh you know they just
want to play it but keep in mind you
often a please have to make sure you
can't be captured your opponent doesn't
have an important counter something like
this alright so next one
all right like to move yes yeah and
don't worry guys they're going to get
harder I just want to show the basic
ones rook d5 check tacking two pieces
are you guys laughing at my problems
already oh my goodness all right
attacking two pieces again I'm making
sure everyone understands the basic
forms of tactics here if you already
know them it'll be done soon all right
pins basic there you go everyone knows
about mostly knows this stuff right I'm
just reviewing it but all right all
right like to move yes
all right so you should know that this
is g2 without having to look at these
little things on the side I'm tempted
you to remove them but I'm not feeling
that mean today so look they're pinning
the night you're going to take a next
move yeah that's right skewer all right
good job guys you found it so skewer it
basically it can you guys tell me the
difference between a skewer in a pin
though very good so for example if a
king is in back you're attacking a rook
and a king's behind it what is that hmm
that's a pin if you're attacking a king
in front and it looks behind it that's a
skewer so always look if the more
valuable piece is in front then that is
a skewer if the more valuable piece is
in back it's a pin the difference is
that usually if it's a skewer they have
to move the piece that's being attacked
if it's a pin they almost can never move
that piece because they're you're going
to take a more valuable piece that make
sense everyone got that all right what
do you know
all right yeah yeah pink jacket all
right nice job all right we're going to
go to the checkmates now boom this if
you do not know this checkmate you
should know it it's the only check on
the board yada yada yes
checkmate back Rick made checkmate the
thing is and I can tell you that this is
something that it seems kind of like a
basic thing but people forget about
background check meant a lot the way it
happens with me like I can tell you how
it works for me is that I feel nervous
if I don't have any space for my King if
I don't have a square for my kingdom
move I actually feel nervous like I'm at
the board I'm like uh something's not
right here you know if my back rank is
weak if I if my back rank doesn't have
many controllers and my king is is like
this I always kind of sense that
something's wrong I always want to make
a pawn move so it's very important to to
always keep this in mind so this kind of
checkmate happens a lot yes I realize
they're easy I'm covering the basis here
yes this is e6
mmm smothering the king bishops here
protecting the Queen sometimes their
their checkmates like this as well but
here the king can escape mother mains so
time for the practice problems they're
not particularly hard but don't worry I
have harder ones if these are
insufficient all right white to move oh
you're thinking yes
yeah well that's clever what's this
called so what happens if I take you and
you got a fork so a lot of tactics and
games are not super basic it's not just
though move a piece here and fork to
pieces often they're combinations of
tactics so this one's actually a
combination between a pin and a fork so
that's why you always want to look at
and I talked about this a ton probably
more than any other subject with my
students I talk about tempo moves what
that means is that you guys know what a
temple move is first of all all right a
temple move is a move that either
capture something makes a threat or in
particular a check so you always want to
look at your temple moves because okay
they may not be good like here Knight g4
is a temple move but the Queen just
moves and who cares right but Bishop
here is also a temple move you'll find
that if you always want to look at your
temple moves always look at your moves
that can threaten your opponent that
makes sense
oh and by the way it works in two ways
you want to look at your opponent's
moves that threaten you right all right
next problem
I'm sure you got it alright good oh my
goodness you're hanging your rook you
know I can take it right she's smiling
at me like whatever all right well I
don't have to but then the Queen will
hang so this is what is this called by
the way and then any foreplay
very nice right all right and by the way
I made these problems up last night so
they're fresh I didn't say anything
while onions who mentioned onions
there's no tactic with onions I've
checked I checked
all right who's got this one are you
think you got it go ahead
Brooke xe6
that's how you write it it doesn't mean
that's how you say it
there we go rook takes c6 by the way
what's wrong with this one
okay where's the rope no move
yeah and defend the night so the thing
is you always want to look at moves like
this because there are threatening moves
but rook here and it doesn't seem like
you can win this night right but if you
do it in the reverse order and then play
here you can win the rook all right
doo doo doo doo doo doo okay a board
full of pieces I bet that's scared you
it can be
yup this is a three that's a pin doesn't
win anything you're pinning the knight
okay say I move here alright so you
found a pimp but remember during the
game like okay if you're doing practice
problems it's good to learn how to find
all the pins all the forks all the
skewers but when you're actually playing
a game in your saw trying to solve
problems always look at the something to
see if your opponent can defend against
it just pinning a knight is usually not
a huge deal it can be annoying but it's
not it's it doesn't like really improve
your position that much right so always
look for your other threatening moves
first remember look for your temple
moves the moves that threaten your
opponent right away always look at those
first and only when those don't work do
you look at other moves yes all right so
you're attacking my bishop well guess
I'll take your pawn all right gotta move
this guy
yeah but this one's better sorry I
actually didn't hear you eat five I
don't see what this one does because I
can just take this pawn okay but have
you won anything I'll take your queen I
guess you haven't achieved that much
right but if you play d5 this is what
kind of tactics is this so this is a
very common one by the way the central
fork often you attack a piece the piece
has to move and then you fork these two
pieces so remember be very careful when
you put your pieces like this you want
to make sure they do not get forked
that's a really sad way to lose a game I
guarantee you almost every experienced
tournament player has either won or lost
a game like this so be very cautious for
this kind of fork alright what else we
got oh my goodness look at this position
alright ah yep
so Queen to d8 it's a nice move so if I
play Queen takes Queen I put you play
rook takes Queen and you check maybe but
did you ask yourself what you're
threatening what are you threatening
here I don't have to take remember this
is another thing that happens a lot
people like to assume that their
opponents are going to go with their
plan they're going to be like I'm going
to do this my opponents going to do this
and I'm going to do this and I'm going
to win yay
but I always assume your opponent wants
to you know mess up your plans so your
plan is to play is to get a back rank
checkmate but if I but if I don't take
your Queen and just play here what are
you going to do okay
are you going to win this position
probably not right so do you have
anything better better yes oh my
goodness so you don't have to take but
if you don't take your downer rook and
now you give the check it's not a me yet
yeah so it's very important you look at
all your tempo moves but keep in mind
this is why you look at temple moves
first Queen takes rook is a temple move
Queen T it does Queen d8 make a threat
then it's not a temple move so always
look at your temple moves first it's an
easy way to do this all right okay if
you guys have seen this pattern can you
put your hand down because if you've
seen it it's very easy if you haven't
seen it it can be very tricky have you
seen this type of one before raise your
hand if you if you think you have the
answer and you haven't seen this pattern
before if all of you have seen the
pattern then we can move on however it
is very cool to find this for the first
time so I want to give people the chance
to do this I remember the first time I
saw this tactical pattern I was
mystified I was like wow you can really
do this seriously I'm not joking
so remember what was my rule of what
kind of moves you look at first temple
moves so for example night check has to
be looked at but I'll just take your
night you pick my night I probably get
myself looked and ok not so bad right
lift means giving your king room by the
way it's a fancy german word it's a very
common in just language yes this is c2
and i just talked about 90 f7 why it's
not so great or at least it's not
amazing all right pink jacket that's
what I'm called that's your name by the
way from now on
just kidding Queen g8 alright you're
giving away your queen you know I can
take your queen right you're aware
you're sure you're good alright look
takes Queen now what oh my goodness the
fact that it's a fork is pretty
irrelevant but yes I'm glad you pointed
that out it's a fork and it's checkmate
but the fact that it's checkmate the
only thing that's important it's kind of
a cool checkmate right so this is
actually a very common version so
usually the way it works is you can
often give a check first come here and
then this smothered mate is a really
cool trick so it's a nice one to
remember this is usually how smothered
made happens you lit this really cool
queen sack again the first time I saw
this I was blown away I was like woah
chess is an awesome game I didn't
realize how cool it was all right here
we go
all right yeah I like how you didn't say
X this time rook takes g6 check so
you're giving away a rook that's cool
very good so often times when you when
you're going for this kind of pattern
there's a piece blocking you so what you
can do is you can move the route you can
move the pieces blocking with tempo and
then move here so what will be wrong
with playing this move by the way yeah
you got to look at your opponents
threats too right and by the way this
tactic is called an x-ray see how the
Queen defends the rook even though
there's a piece in the way that's an
x-ray x-rays are kind of cool although I
always have this weird image when they
really it's like you're at the doctor's
office or my playing chess what's going
on anyway so you got to be careful all
right so these were mostly to tack the
practice stuff so now I'm actually going
to show you the problems that I gave the
other group which is which are a little
bit more complicated a little bit this
one should be easy for you because we
looked at it recently
to do and by the way to know who's to
play there's a little sign here I made
yep
this is this is f so you're giving away
a rook my goodness all right I'll take
it do you really think I'm going to fall
for this one really I'm going to let you
just checkmate me here all right I'll
take your rook and then oh my goodness
he's threatening mate I'll block never
assume your opponent's going to go with
your plan always assume your opponent
going to mess up your plan which is why
you need to find a continuation that
does not let them mess up your plan yes
all you have to look at those
coordinates this one the other one
really all right I'll take your rook I'm
game
I fell for it what's the trick all right
be careful please do not give away your
pieces pretend pretend they actually are
your pieces your chest children I don't
I don't go that far because then you're
then you're not going to want to like
imagine you could trade a bishop for
your opponent's Queen you're gonna be
like I don't give up my bishop it's a
child but I don't like that comparison
but okay you want to give them away for
free so slightly less valuable than
children but you know all right yes all
right rook e8 check we already covered
this one ticks very good
so now this isn't checkmate immediately
but how is black and a stop Queen g7
mate it's impossible now and this
problem was actually very tricky because
this move looked very tempting trying to
attack the Queen and then play the
checkmate right but here black can
escape with this move and now do you
guys see the defensive move very good
and now you cover the meet and now
blacks keep in mind white started out
down at night and upon so if you don't
mate here you're probably in trouble all
right here we go
yes
oh my goodness
very good so you start with a capture a
tempo move which usually forces a
response then you get a skewer so now
then the King has to move and now you
can take the rook but just to show you
why every detail in a position can
matter if this pawn we're back here this
wouldn't be a good idea why not because
there's a checkmate right but because
the King is an escape square it's good
so you see how every little detail in a
position can matter you have to look at
things to the very end because it
imagine you you you think you skewer
your opponent you get a nice tactic
you're patting yourself on the back and
then you get checkmate it trust me it's
happened to everyone it's a very
depressing experience but the key thing
is to make sure that this is impossible
all right we'll do this one this one's
kind of a cool sorry next time and you
don't have a pink jacket on anymore so I
don't know your name Nemo it's okay when
I give you a position did I say you were
going to win I didn't say anything I
just said it was white to play and said
good luck I didn't even say good look so
it's white to move so here your Bishop
Black has a tactic here what kind of
tactic is this pin and the bishops
attacked so you're in a pin so your job
is you you they lose a bishop or a look
right now so your job is to fight to
find any way to get out of this pin and
to do that you need to really find some
from some tactics yes is that a question
or a statement you're saying it is
Bishop takes e5 have some confidence
it's okay if you're wrong then it's
alright nothing bad is going to happen
so Bishop takes e5 so now both the and
this is a common trick by the way if you
have two pieces hanging you might as
well take stuff with one of them it's
actually a nice trick because then your
opponent can only take one piece at a
time even so if you have lots of pieces
hanging it's actually not always so bad
just because your opponent you know they
only have one move to take them right
they can't take all your pieces in one
move that would be really depressing but
they can only take one at a time and
meanwhile one piece can often do some
damage so Bishop takes pawn so I don't
want to allow the rook to be taken right
so I'll probably take this and now
check and what's this yeah you can call
them either I like the word fork just
because I like silverware but you can
actually call it either a double attack
is easier I guess but okay so King moves
and then take the knight and now okay
Bishop in two pawns for a rook what's
that that's all we have here bishop in
two pawns for a rook yeah not bad
considering you started out pinned with
your pinned piece attack right you do
yeah so you started off in trouble but
now you're probably going to draw right
so sometimes you use tactics to get
yourself out of trouble rather than you
know rather than to win the game
sometimes you use tactics to save the
game so this is also something you want
to look for all right oh this is a fun
one
yes
very good this is why looking at the
most forcing move right away is actually
a very good habit to get into because
Queen takes pawn the thing is you know
you you want to not consider this move
because you're like wait I'm hanging a
queen what is this but you always want
to look at it because sometimes it can
end up well and here this is a very nice
mate right it's actually a back rank
mate on the edge of the board is the way
I look at it a back rake made on the
side of the board but with the bishop
controlling two squares a pawn here and
a rook mate but that's the thing like in
this position you should notice that the
rook and Queen are aiming at your
opponent's king that should be one of
the first things you pick up on so you
know you want to look it moves like
Bishop takes pawn but the here black can
escape with something like this and now
the knight can block this check see that
Knights can actually be very annoying
defenders because they control some key
squares around a king so black to move
black to move it says so right here
you actually have mate in three in this
position mate and three I usually don't
give away this information so but I'm
feeling generous for some reason all
right checkmate in three moves which
means you look at your forcing moves all
right guys you you are on the right path
however here you did not consider all of
your tempo moves you got it clean up -
I'll take you
yeah go ahead oh look at this one so I
have to take you and now you guys see it
mate with the night covering the two
squares so it's a back rank mate pretty
tricky right the hard part is Lauren is
making yourself hang your queen it's not
easy to do but the easy way to consider
these moves and look at every move that
is a chec or like ir a forcing move
Queen do you want notice how every
single move was the most forcing move
every single move you only gave white
one move think about this okay ah this
one yeah we're getting trickier and
trickier here it's okay remember to be
calm it's white to play it says so here
remember Oh
Tampa moves yep all right another temple
move that gives away a piece I like it
all right
so Queen takes Knight it's actually an
excellent try so now if Luke takes Queen
yeah so now you have to be careful
though the thing is you're threatening
the Queen and checkmate which is good
but first of all there's rook down to e1
check might throw a wrench in the works
but there's also Queen e8 and I don't
see how you're going to meet see how the
Queen covers the mate but that's a good
try but you have to look at it to the
very end and make sure your opponent
can't cover your threats it's actually a
very sneaky move the hard move to see is
the move right here so it is unexpected
but you have to force yourself to look
at it because it is what kind of move
the forcing move or a temple move yes so
the bishop attacks the knight so the
idea is that if you're if you're able to
take the knight then this bishop is
going to hang right
if this Knight moves on the bishop hangs
see that because you have two pieces and
only one defender the bishop blocks the
rook from defending then the bishop kind
of a clever move right now if if you
take the bishop what happens hmm and
this is check and a fork right and this
is really cool so you start out with
that attack then this is actually called
a diversion tactic because you're
diverting the rook in order to take
another piece and then if the rook moves
you use a different tactic which is I've
Queen e8 then I'll play King b7 I'm not
going to give away my queen yeah
and now you use a pin because the rook
doesn't attack this right because you're
pinned and now you're going to win this
rook or the Queen or something so it's
going to be over see that so look for
these unexpected moves a lot of the
times in your games they're going to be
everywhere but the key way you find it
is always look how your opponent can
threaten you how you can threaten your
opponent and look for all these tactics
for skewers pins a lot of the time the
way you're going to win material from
your opponent or the way they're going
to win it from you is using one of these
tactics so be on the lookout just always
look for this stuff for both you and
your opponent and I'm telling you your
results are going to improve a lot
because most of your games are going to
be won or lost based on some kind of
material win like this